welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar making data fly
in formation it is presented by Chuck
Donnelly CEO and founder at Rock step
solutions and Julie Morrison vice
president and principal at Rock step
solutions my name is Judy O'Rourke and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots leopards is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box our speakers will respond
to your questions the email following
the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now about
further ado please join me in welcoming
Chuck Donnelly and Julie Morrison I will
now turn the presentation over to them
thanks Judy really excited to be here
today and given this presentation about
making data fly in formation and we're
gonna talk a lot about what that really
means and when you think about a data is
the embodiment of all human knowledge so
this is really an exciting field for us
and I've been working in working with
data from astrophysics to biomedical
data for the last 30 years have
collected data and worked with data from
outer space and then more recently
working with genomics data and genetics
data lab informatics data proteomics
data all kinds of data really excited
about having the opportunity today to
talk about data so I'm gonna turn it
over to Julie to introduce herself
quickly and then we'll get on with it
thanks Chuck I'm sure
Morrison and my background is really in
generating data analyzing compiling and
reporting on data and for the last few
years I've been taking that knowledge
and helping organizations and people
just like you guys to take all of their
different sources of data across the
spectrum and bring them all together so
they can start getting new insights that
weren't possible when they were all
separate silos so I'm excited to start
talking a little bit more about that
today
all right thanks Julie so just a quick
overview outline of what we're gonna
talk about today we're gonna frame the
problem so what is the problem we're
gonna talk about that kind of put it in
context and then we're gonna go through
a case study this is a really exciting
case study where we've actually solved
some major data problems we're gonna
talk about industry 4.0 the fourth
revolution if you will in the industry
that has led to lab 4.0 and
digitalization which is different from
digitization so this is gonna be a real
core and important part of the
presentation today and then we get to
the core of it really with making data
fly in formation and we'll talk about
what that means talk about data 360 what
that means situational awareness and the
lab of the future so put your seatbelts
on this is gonna be exciting all right
so I like to make some big bold
projections here and these are really
important because it kind of bookmark
our presentation today but in 10 years
from now digital technology capabilities
will double this is really a dramatic
statement when you think about it
because this doubling of technology
every 10 years means that in the next 10
years the digital technologies that are
developed will eclipse all of the
digital technologies that have been
developed since the beginning of digital
time and this doubling keeps happening
about every 10 years or so another
predict projection that we're gonna make
which is also very transformative is
that in 10 years from now robots will
perform most or many of the lab tasks
that are currently done by humans in
your lab so this is also like people
think this is crazy but when you think
about self-driving cars we have robots
now that are on this
streets driving cars making incredibly
complex decisions in real time and these
are life-and-death decisions so the
robots have become incredibly
sophisticated and we're gonna see that
moving into our laboratories lastly I
want to say that artificial intelligence
algorithms will be your partner in
research so that you will publish papers
with artificial intelligence algorithms
as co-authors on your paper and you
think about it the time you go to get
your coffee and sit down and artificial
intelligence algorithm running on a
high-performance computer can read all
of the journal articles in PubMed that
are related to your research digest that
data using AI algorithms to help guide
you to your next steps in your research
is gonna be enormously important it's
already happening today and we're gonna
see a lot more of that in the future so
the problem is data are hard to find
it's just as simple as that believe it
or not people are still collecting data
on binders and spreadsheets and paper
and pen and it's really not scalable
it's really not gonna take us to the
future so many organizations have
petabytes of data that really contain
the cures for diseases and they can't
really get at the data they can't
integrate the data can ask new questions
of old data and so this data of value
business value of data are not being
achieved and in the process the return
on investment for drug discovery is
dropping precipitously from about 10%
only seven years ago to about three
percent now and this was a in a report
from Deloitte so this kind of these
kinds of problems now are really pushing
us towards digitalization so what does
this all mean what how do we get here
you know we have all of these different
data sources all of these different data
bases and they're all connected with
little different connections and you
have you know copying and pasting and
all these little arrows between all of
the databases and the data sources and
it
turns out to be after a while becomes a
web of information that is really
impossible to really obtain business
value from them that many connections of
data and and so the basically what
happens as we redo experiments because
we can't find the data we can't find the
connections between the data elements
and we redo experiments which is causing
this ROI to drop precipitously it's one
of the causes so what are we trying to
do we're going to talk about
digitalization and again this is
different than digitized we're talking
about a digitalization experiment
experience and will define what that
means more but it's really about
connecting the dots it's really about
bringing all of the data together so
that you have a 360 degree view inside
your data and you have complete
situational awareness of what's going on
in your research laboratory so we put
together this case study and I you know
of course dramatize this to make it
sound like you know a news breaking news
article but when you think about it this
is really kind of what's happening I say
data tsunami nearly drowns a small
research lab rock step solutions that's
our company team wrangles the data and
then deploys informatics systems to
control data floods and rescue the
research so you know while this is a
dramatization of it is actually kind of
true it is really true and Julie's gonna
take this to the next to the next spot
here and talk about exactly what
happened in this research lab thanks Joe
Frank so to frame us a little bit this
is an an aging study this is a
partnership between dr. Gary Churchill's
laboratory at the Jackson laboratory and
one of the alphabet companies and
essentially dr. Turk chose laboratories
doing sponsored research for this
alphabet company and they're
specifically exploring diet and caloric
intake on overall health and longevity
of mice so they're breaking them into
cohorts feeding them different diets and
doing a huge range of high-throughput
genotyping on these animals as you can
imagine that generates an enormous
volume of data
and they were having a real trouble
wrangling that and also getting maximum
value from that much data and we'll talk
about why so the data were overwhelming
when we came into the project there were
over 1,300 spreadsheets and media files
and were 93 thousand data points being
emailed around and put into file share
folders and as you can imagine the
alphabet company wanted to just put it
right into their Google of algorithms
and get on with their analysis so there
was a real problem getting value when
there's 1,300 spreadsheets of data and
your Wranglers are spending time trying
to piece them all together and copy
pasting and they were really losing
control of it there was a huge waste of
energy and resources and the quality
control was actually difficult to manage
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that in just a moment so some of the
things that they needed for this study
was the ability to track all of the data
and all of the data points around each
individual animal from the time it
entered their facility whether it comes
from a CRO or an animal breeding or if
it comes from in-house they needed to
track all of that the data and clinical
health records associated with that
animal because these are longevity
studies so they they had a rich amount
of data coming in from the animals and
also with the resources so there were a
lot of different components happening a
lot of different tests in this phenotype
and pipeline and they really needed to
preserve the chain of custody with the
samples and the audit who did what any
investigations on process or data points
were easily needed to be easily resolved
I mean again we're kind of getting to
that data QC point when if something is
not quite going right how do you resolve
that and what is what did that look like
and we'll talk about that again in a
moment so manage workflows so we said
1,300 spreadsheets so can you imagine
for a moment taking you know this
example is a blood chem that came off of
an instrumentation imagine
emailing these back and forth and now
you're trying to compile this with your
body weights with your animal health
observations for the day it's totally
out of control and chaos so now in climb
which is our platform for managing this
data the instrumentation files and all
of those spreadsheets can be
automatically just dropped with a drag
and drop into the system and as you can
see here this is a simplistic example
there's not many data points some of
these files could have hundreds of
columns of data but just as easily
dragged into the system and now all of
this data is structured and searchable
regardless of where it came from
regardless of the body weight or an
instrumentation or an Eliza etc and now
their clients also have data delivery
pretty much on demand in real time so
aggregating and harmonizing you're gonna
hear these words a lot and I'm not gonna
drill into them too much because I know
Chuck's gonna spend some time on them
later but really the idea of bringing
all these different disparate types of
data together and using the same terms
to describe them so that they're
searchable so for this particular use
case we took two years of legacy data
and loaded it into climb the data are
now searchable across time across study
types across tasks however the client
wants to get to that data and they're
normalized and harmonized sorrywhat
talked a lot about the data QC tools the
data reviews are actually conducted in
real time in the application there are
visual indicators that show whether
values are out of range and these are
specified by the investigator when they
set up their tasks in the system now
there's a visual indicator to the
technician entering the data that they
might have a typo really eliminating
that for a human error
there's also sensors and other things
that can run side by side with the data
quality to start running ml anomaly
detection algorithms on the data data
points but really ultimately getting to
the point where the data cue
see is those happening in the
application and speeding it up for your
checks after and we'll talk about that
in our wrap-up
so chunks laughing because he loves this
slide I first thing I said was I love
talking about the API but I don't know
what you have a naked little guy chunky
guy walking across an API data stream so
if you have if you also wonder that feel
free to send him a message I can email
you the answer but our API our API is
really what enables this alphabet
company to get that data delivery in
real time so while the customer the
turtle lab is entering data directly
into climb the client this alphabet
company can go in via the API use the
strings thingy pull exactly the data out
that they need and it goes right into
their algorithms for analysis so they
have a real time disability into the
data and the operations and it really
has simplified the holes emailing back
and forth and spreadsheets it's now a
matter of a few mouse clicks so what
what are the benefits here you have a
picture of dr. Gary Churchill and really
the primary benefit was in the
organization and the accessibility of
the data really spreadsheets were not
going back and forth anymore they felt
like there was a real organization that
they could access they could access the
data for their operational efficiency
but the client could also access it in
real time for their analysis and they we
talked a little bit about their project
management and scheduling and that's
actually helping them see benefits today
but as this pipeline of tests on these
animals grow over five or six years in
theory they're gonna save so much time
retrieving quality checking analyzing
the data and their studies over time and
I think of it a lot like even drug
discovery ten years from now when you go
to file your IND what actually happened
was your data really organized and
accessible from ten years ago so very
similar here in the longevity study so
to wrap things up it's very cliche
we want everyone to be happy and the
client is now happy they have harmonized
and aggregated data they're pulling out
via the web API there's no more
spreadsheets being emailed around the
lab is happy because all the clients
happy but they're also getting new data
insights they are their operational
efficiency this is the data point I was
mentioning earlier if there was an
anomaly detected into data it could take
over two weeks to track down who did
what what happened now they're saying it
can happen in less than two hours
to resolve data inefficiencies or data
mistakes and so everyone is happy on
that part and we're happy because we can
support this lab across their entire
journey to digital transformation so
whether they were manually entering
things in paper and just getting them
into spreadsheets or whether it's
spreadsheets coming off of instruments
that you can drop in to the system or
we're pulling in data streams from api's
like those IOT sensors or data streams
from other instruments regardless of
whether we're this lab was or where you
are in your digital journey it will kind
of depend on where you are or all of the
above and how you move from being a
digitized lab to a digitalized lab so
I'm going to turn it back over to Chuck
and he's going to make sure that you
understand the difference between
digitization and Thank You Julie and
just so you know and now I'm happy
because you use that slide I really
appreciate that but this is really a
powerful story when you think about it
because this is research that was being
conducted that is being conducted now
much more efficiently and it's because
of this digital transformation that's
making this all possible and so I want
to talk about how like kind of what are
some of the models that have got us here
to digital transformation and where it
is going and we'll start with the model
of industry so we're in the fourth
Industrial Revolution has arrived now an
industry where they're now and if you go
back in time you see the steam engine
that came into being you know in the 17
1800s when it was transformative all of
a sudden you could have
something other than muscle and horses
and you know oxen doing work but you
could actually have motors don't work
working seven days a week 24/7 whatever
and offering a lot of energy putting a
lot of energy into manufacturing and
then of course Ford Henry Ford in the
1900s with the assembly line another
transformative event in industry where
all the sudden cars it looked like
they're being made in a week or it
looked like cars are being made every
hour even though it took months to make
a car that would go through the assembly
line when you looked at the end of that
assembly line cars are coming off every
hour another transform a transformative
event in industry where all of a sudden
mass production was possible and in
quality control and then in the 70s and
80s we started seeing robotic systems
come into play that controlled by
computers but still these robotic
systems while it was transformative
because now you had these robotic arms
that could do things that people were
doing they still did not have the
intelligence if you will to do anything
different than what they're programmed
to do when they started their task but
now with the digital transformation and
the smart the industry 4.0 we have
intelligent computers computers that can
think with artificial intelligence
algorithms and that can learn while
they're working controlling these
robotic arms and that is really the
massive transformation that is happening
now and that's what's bringing us things
like self-driving cars and the robots
that you're gonna see in your research
lab so I'm gonna take back and give you
an example of a data intensive industry
that is now digitized and you can kind
of use this as an example of where are
we gonna see the laboratory data going
you know the data intensive biomedical
industry going so if we look at the
airline industry or the travel industry
in general they definitely embrace
digitalization but back in the 60s their
late sickly 50s early 60s when you got
your ticket and believe me I can
remember that when if you got your
ticket you actually was written on with
pencil and paper and if you lost your
ticket you're basically out of luck
it was not a scalable system you could
not go back and find another copy of
your ticket maybe somebody had a Carbon
Copy in a file cabinet somewhere but
basically it was a very manual system
and not scalable and then in the you
know a little bit later a decade or so
later we started seeing digital systems
databases that were tracking these
render these reservations online and
your tickets were being printed out and
now you have a digitized system so again
digitized not digitized but we have now
databases a huge inflection point in
terms of ability to operate a scalable
organization or industry and then we
started seeing these electronic systems
which I separate from digitized to
electronic where you actually have these
little kiosks where you can go and get
your tickets and but it's still it's
kind of it's you can you just accessing
the database yourself
but now the travel industry we just
traveled recently to San Francisco and
you know got my plane tickets on on the
phone and they never even had a printed
copy of the plane ticket my itinerary
was booked on the same application my
hotel my car and when I got off the
airplane actually on my return there
wasn't really amazing that we're in
Maine it's cold and a van was waiting
for me at the back with the baggage drop
was and picked me up brought me to my
car the car was warmed up and they knew
that I had arrived because they were
watching the flight schedules and they
knew that I was nearby because I had
tracking on my phone and so they knew
where I was and this whole
digitalization process was sort of
playing how making my life a lot easier
at this point and then when I got in my
car I typed in my directions where I was
going and my computer my GPS was telling
me where to go and then there are
traffic tie-ups in' and it told me to
take different routes to save two
minutes and you can see how this like
this whole complete and and
digitalization that has taken you
through this journey of your whole
travel experience
and giving you a prescriptive using the
data for prescriptive analysis to give
you different options for where you're
going and how to get there so really
embraced in the travel industry and
we're just starting to see that now in
the research lab so I call this the meri
meeting of technologies that are all
coming together in the research in the
biomedical research lab via machine
learning artificial intelligence
Internet of Things we'll talk a little
bit more about all of these things
digital assistants augmented reality and
mobile services all sort of coming
together at this time for the research
lab and it's gonna be an inflection
point of paradigm shifting in the next
ten years as the technologies mature and
as our digital capabilities double in
the next ten years so already and we'll
talk a little bit more about this
there's laboratory systems that have
artificial intelligence built into them
that can watch data as the data are
arriving so in this little cartoon
example here we see some data points we
see more data points arriving we see
artificial intelligence algorithms that
are finding patterns in the data and
then they can transfer that data to the
informatics platforms and lead to
discovery sooner so you know this is
obviously a cartoon example here but
these are real life systems now that
we're gonna actually talk a little bit
more about that can do this and actually
accelerate discovery and find biomarkers
quicker and help find the cures faster
for research so we're going to this is a
whole talk now we're getting into the
part where we're talking about making
data fly in formation and I was in San
Francisco and I was watching the Blue
Angels fly and this was like a moment
was a kind of pivotal moment in my you
know an aha moment if you will as
watching these Jets flying I'm thinking
why are they flying in formation what's
so important about that how does that
translate maybe to my work in data and
you know you're looking at them they're
either more aerodynamic they're more
energy efficient they have mutual
protection and they have more pinpoint
accuracy and there's some technologies
why that is but anyway there's reasons
why these Jets fly in formation and if
we
look at data if we think about sort of
similar bringing data together in these
high-precision systems where you have
this better precision informatics to
make these data more valuable and that
may allow for better decision-making
better business value usability
reproducibility and reduce the rework
that you have to do because the data are
accessible and they're aligned and
they're in formation if you will and I
love the the pun there information and
information that was intentional in case
you didn't get it now I've let that out
so what does it mean to have data
information what does it mean so we
talked about aggregating the data and
and Julie presented the case study where
we brought together these data these
data that were in spreadsheets coming
from different instruments and they were
hard to find they're being emailed
around so now the data are aggregated
they're centralized that's a good thing
you can centralized data you can
aggregate data but you need to harmonize
the data and that is even a bit more
that is very difficult in fact in a lot
of cases it means bringing the data
together with vocabularies consistent
vocabularies to annotate the data so
that you can actually compare data and
search data across different data sets
and actually come up with meaningful
results because the data are harmonized
now I wanted to say that harmonizing
data is a big challenge it's one of the
things that we try to do that we do in
our company bringing data together but
it is an enormous challenge because
different ontologies look at data in
different ways so you might have the
disease ontology talking about cancer or
the kidney and then you might have a
genomics ontology talking about the
various mutations that are
characterizing a cancer and you might
even be having the same cancer annotated
with two different ontologies and how do
you bring them together that's a
challenge that's beyond the scope of
this presentation today but I want to
there are a number of organizations that
spend all of their energy working on
that and it's really important the data
needs to be searchable if they're
harmonized and aggregated then you need
a search engine on the data and that's
what we did with the
with the Churchill lab and the taste
study they can go to a platform they can
find the data and the data need to be
accessible accessible is uh there's a
lot of facets to that if you will
there's a handicap-accessible if you
have the if your vision impaired or
hearing impaired but it's also
accessible because you have the right to
get to the data and the data need to be
reusable if you will so the IP the
intellectual property rights need to be
set up so that the data can be reusable
and all of those things coming together
make the data very integratable and add
business value to the data so you can
have those petabytes of data and you can
actually find new cures in data without
having to do new experiments so I'm
gonna turn it back over to Julie who's
gonna talk about data 360 now and we'll
see where that goes so I'll try to keep
it continued I love talking about it
because it reminds me of one of my
favorite shows Sherlock
so if you watch the BD so Sherlock BBC
show Sherlock there is an episode where
they really go into detail about how
Sherlock Holmes can pull all of these
random factoids and data spots from his
mind at anytime and associate it with
seemingly random things to get new
observations and do new insights and
this is what data 360 is so if you can
think about here on this side we have a
simple example of a data a research
object in your database so here's the
mouse it can be a compound it could be a
study or an indication but for now we'll
just say we have this animal we want to
know everything about it we have all of
these separate data silos around it you
know they're pedigrees or protocols the
proteome everything about them so if you
can imagine for a minute going into your
mind Palace and you have this animal and
being able to reach in and grab the
information on the phenotype and what
test was done and you did a rota rod and
then what were the results of that and
how many times does it run in which
technician and you get the idea really
drilling down into this and being able
to look around and get any of the
associated with this animal and linked
it all together this is really the idea
of data 360 so as Chuck said it's really
putting a searchable component to the
data so if we have data that's not
sitting in silos that are all coming
together into a uniform searchable
output then we can actually start
learning new things of the data so for
example we may want to research an
indication acute lymphoblastic leukemia
so we go into our database we want to
say what does our organization done on
this before alright so we can there's 40
studies that's been done at different
locations across our organization
there's some other things I think I want
to look at this particular inhibitor and
I want to see a map view of it so if we
look at this kind of cartoon version of
a mind map we can really drill into one
particular study and again start
reaching out to different parts at the
data to start asking questions will show
me all the phenotypes show me what was
molecularly done and even drill down
piece by piece to get more and more data
to associate with this particular point
so we can take that particular study and
maybe we want to drill into it a
different way so we have the same study
we were just visualizing with the mind
map but now we want to look at a
dataview so just show me everything that
we've got in the database on this
particular study actually so I want to
drill down and some ice there's 35 mice
associated with it it's going to shows
us all of their names we can choose the
ones that are of interest and maybe we
want to know what their genotypes were
what what assays have been run what the
calls were what phenotyping has been
done what were the IOT what were the
sensor saying about their environmental
conditions at that time and did it have
a impact on their microbiome let's say
so now we have three mice that has data
on that you can see we're drilling into
further and further levels to get
exactly what we want to see and
overlaying totally different data silos
together to get information in one and
this is the type of thing that you can
then export out to your favorite nowis
engine like power bi or Spotfire work a
Google algorithm and here are some
examples of ways that
data has been overlaid so you can see
the graph of the environmental sensors
the IOT sensors plotting against body
weights for that day so if you maybe you
had some really weird anomalous body
weights you can go back and look at the
environmental conditions and see that oh
those two cages were actually had a
really high humidity that day I wonder
if that had an impact on it so again
starting to ask the data different
questions just like in your mind palace
where Sherlock could take all of those
random data points now you're starting
to say did this really weird phenotype
actually affect the genotype over here
or did it affect the animal health we
saw here starting to take all those data
points and make sense of them so
ultimately you know there's kind of the
old adage of garbage in garbage out and
we're hearing that more and more like
junk data and junk data out AI is only
as good as our data and the data has to
be aggregated harmonized searchable if
we can give the a guy out where them's
good data then they can give us deep
knowledge and learning we all ultimately
want to get descriptive and prescriptive
guidance in real time so we can start
making better decisions that our go
no-go decisions in real time and
ultimately accessing information
regardless of whether it came from so at
each stage of your discovery and
development regardless of indication
across disease or therapeutic areas
across buildings across global
organization pulling together all of the
information about the compounds the
biomarkers the efficiency really pulling
together all of that data so that you
can start getting better insights
throughout the entire pipeline and while
you know this idea of data 360 and
bringing all the data in is still
aspirational it's something that is very
much happening now and it's the holy
grail with me to have every data point
in your organization fed into one area
where you can access it like a nine
palace to start bridging seemingly
different data areas to get better
insights
new insights well that's really exciting
Tilly and it is you know I still
mentioned this is aspirational if you
will but actually we're a long way
towards that now the technologies are
actually there now it's a matter of
changing the behaviors and putting the
energy into this transformation this
digitalization so it's really it's
exciting it's aspirational but you know
you have to aspire to something in order
to get to the next level so another
thing that comes out of this data 360
who becomes essentially part of it if
you will is this concept of situational
awareness and I go back to the concept
of the Blue Angels they have this out
this helmet on that gives them a
360-degree view of everything that's
going on around those planes they have
dashboards that give them status
information on the flight platform that
they're flying and they have threat
detection built right in so they get
alerts and they have predictive
information that tells them something
about the future and prescriptive
information that tell are prescriptive
algorithms that tell them about things
that can maybe help them defend
themselves so this kind of you know
situational awareness applies to the
research lab believe it or not because
we don't want our researchers walking
around with helmets like that much
rather have them you know looking like
researchers and acting like researchers
but we can give them this 360 degree
view with this situational awareness
using informatics platforms that are
capturing the data in real time and this
is what we're doing with the case study
that we provided you know they can
actually get at the data have a
360-degree view
sit down and a platform and know exactly
what's going on in the research lab
who's doing what kind of work when and
what the statuses of those that work and
if there's problems that arise we are
building systems now with IOT devices so
that we can actually monitor the
environmental health or monitor the
health of freezers and have
anomaly detection algorithms which we
are running now which actually can
detect problems maybe before they become
serious problems send an alert so that
those problems can be resolved and then
predictive or predictive information
about what's gonna happen in the future
so if you see this anomaly happening in
a voltage stream on a freezer for
example you might know that that freezer
is about to fail and you have some
predictive information to help guide you
to a better a better outcome so all of
these things are happening now and
they're happening now because of the
cloud it's one of the technologies that
have transformed all of this in fact
this isn't really the core technology
that's transformed and brought us to
this time where we have digitalization
and in this view here you can see we
have these Data Platform
with different panels of data all
aggregated and views mobile devices so
that you can actually find the data
while you are on the subway if you want
you can actually look at your data but
you can the data you are born mobile now
with these devices there's the systems
and the data are aggregated harmonized
and searchable so that's where we are
making progress right now we've solved
this problem in a lot of areas so now we
come back to Sherlock's mind Palace if
you will Thank You Julie for that I
hadn't really thought about that but
this is what it is it's really getting
to a place where you can actually
explore your data from the inside and
actually look at it from a digital
perspective so we are working right now
on something which we call the digital
twin this is not unique to us but the
digital twin is taking the physical
world and in real time digitizing it so
that artificial intelligence algorithms
can actually be looking at the physical
world through this digital data streams
and actually making predictions and
discoveries in real time as I showed you
prior in a slide earlier where you have
these dots coming in this is actually
now we're working with a company called
volume they have these K these are
caging systems with artificial
intelligence algorithms built into the
caging systems and then there's
platforms like climb that can actually
provide the informatics platform for
them so that the researchers can
actually actually follow what's going on
with the data and you have this digital
twin which is now the bringing us the
lab of the future and it really is that
inflection point that I was talking
about lab 4.0 is actually here and
coming now and maturing so if I am
working with climb as an informatics
tool in the cloud and I am on the edge
is really a powerful the power of the
future if you will power in the future
so we talked about these things out
there that are streaming data in their
IOT devices they could be a monitoring
environment they could be monitoring you
know various systems that are running
whether it's freezers it could be
proteomics data all of these data is
streaming to centralized platforms and
the data are aggregated so we call it a
things platform if you will is that core
informatics place where all of the your
data stream to but I want to put up a
couple of and want to motivate with fear
here but there's some things to be
concerned about or things to look out
for as you're planning this so there's a
lot of vendors or manufacturers out
there to have IOT enabled devices or AI
devices and they are really really
powerful and slick but they might be
creating new data silos and that's not
the problem that you want to get into is
you have really cool systems out there
building more data silos so you really
end up with limited data for business
value and so it's really about bringing
these data into the cloud and the clouds
are this is really an important slide in
in many ways because a lot of people
don't understand that cloud hosted is
not the same as pure cloud so a lot of
systems have been taken that were built
for on-premises there in you
the rooms have now been moved to the
cloud and it really hasn't been that's
not a digital transformation you're
taking a digitalized or a digitized
system a system that digitized your lab
and you're moving it into the cloud but
it's just really moving I don't want to
say moving the problem these are good
systems and a lot of cases but you're
not really getting that access to the
pure cloud technologies
unless it's architected for the cloud
and then you can have that data
aggregation system that has access to
all of these cloud technology such as
artificial intelligence machine learning
mobile services and IOT devices and
things like that so that's what we call
cloud enhance so I love the metaphor of
the cloud because the clouds are
constantly changing you look up in the
sky and you see everything changing but
the clouds themselves are actually
constantly changing and getting more and
more and more technologically capable
and this is where that transformation
from then over the next ten years as
digital technologies begin to double
again you will get that access to that
through these clouds so just be a little
bit cautious about what kind of cloud
systems you adopt so why do we need to
make data fly in formation this is the
crux of this question today we talked
about the the digital the you know
bookending it again with you know
technology doubling and robots coming
into play and you know this is this
whole digital transformation that we're
talking about and artificial
intelligence algorithms becoming your
partners in the research lab so we need
to make the data ready for the future
and we need to make our labs ready for
the future and if we don't it's sort of
the same old thinking same old result so
we've seen since 2010 the return on
investment drop from ten percent down to
three percent 2017 this is a precipitous
drop and we need to start looking at
digitalization and artificial
intelligence and things like that
in order to help improve that ROI so our
company Rock step solutions is
digitalizing the animal lab and really
moving into other areas of research as
well so I want to thank you for taking
the time I want to thank Julie for being
here and given a great present being
part of this presentation and we're
gonna take any questions after I think
through email and and thank you very
much really appreciate this Thank You
Chuck and Julie for your informative
presentations I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 14 to 2019 as a final
reminder our speakers will follow up
with any questions you've submitted via
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we will see you next time
goodbye